and we have somebody that I've known for
44 years know 45 44 years 44 years I've
known 32 years 24 32 or 44 32 yeah
that's pretty - yeah all right
he's 32 sure I'm 35 my skin 38 all right
fine 38 so we've got my brother
you really are reverse aging when you
Pope when you poke your head through the
door
talk to me yeah I was like holy [ __ ]
yeah you are you look younger
yeah you're like she says the right
things yeah you are
you're Benjamin Button oh shut up
[ __ ] up about life I want a first up
making amends now I haven't introduced
to you before you do that I want to make
apology yeah yeah yeah I'm kalila I'm
sorry for bringing Kirby it was not
mindful for me to check with you first
it's fine I won't do it again it's fine
you know what that is right we know what
I call that 10 years of sobriety mmm
give him Morano applause let me just
celebrate 10 years of sobriety yeah well
I told Steve old Steve was a [ __ ] her
Kirby stays and all that stuff no no no
I realize that bug me it was his she you
know what can I get this guy so much his
life's good I love him so much
goodbye fan yeah actually yeah he needs
like therapy or he needs to start going
more medias no let me see something
I'm monotone Bob right now and right but
you don't want me I'm like the hawk
there what do you mean wait wait no I'm
not I'm just saying monotone I do yeah I
know but monotone Bob right if you
enrage him enough he turns into regular
all right so right now Monica and Bob
I'm there's veins sticking out of
monotones Bob's face he's turning a
little green but not fully green and I
haven't grown so let me say something
what the [ __ ] do you mean by that
no I think it would help you though yeah
what's wrong with I have no anger you
want to talk about anger Doctor Who
choi korean yeah yeah I feel like that's
perfect he probably understands a Korean
family dynamics in their age yes yeah
and he used to yeah and he yeah he
understands yeah can I see this so right
now yeah and I'm not just between you
and me right I'm not gonna say nothing I
swear to god I'm not and I'm not I'm
just saying that you could talk about
dr. Troy all you want I could say a
couple of things right now to get you
back I'm not gonna do that I'm gonna do
this but it's right now good right now
look at me right now write all the words
I could say no I good you back into a
rage mode I know you as well I know just
as well no guys quit [ __ ] rewind the
last time we all did a podcast you put
him in the red zone
yeah that's how your brain works I know
your pain won't call me what bang Bane
you know what you're like what penguin
the penguin did I always thought he was
the creepiest of all villains yeah still
to this day any we're really good to see
you
really thanks for doing it Steven Lee is
my guest here on Tiger belly really good
to see you you okay yeah I'm fine
- I do I know who doesn't need therapy
look at me right now dude look at me
right now who's the healthiest guy
you've ever met in your life not you but
you don't know I don't I don't hate it I
don't need it though right but you do
need to go to more me know know who
doesn't need who doesn't need to go to
more meeting at least once or twice okay
that's good that's fine that's fair
once or twice Congrats on ten years okay
all right so
[Music]